if you want make a subheading here which
is
transforming the trick
now
what we're going to do is
that's very messy sorry about that what
we're going to do is we're going to use
a mathematical tool actually a series of
mathematical tools that you've been
learning over the last two years to
change this trick to transform it right
and I wonder how many of you have worked
out which trick it is I just haven't
told you what topic of maths we're in
I've just been making you do the math
without telling you what's going on okay
firstly do you need to clean that just
hold on to it for now we'll move it
later
firstly what we're going to do is to
transform the trick you need to
understand the trick well yourself right
so let's actually rehearse the basic
tricks and this the basic fact this will
help you actually perform it later if
you forget okay how many cards how many
cards when we did the standard trick
did you give to the person that you were
performing the trick on how many nine
cards okay so you give nine cards
now what that means is once like they
select their card and it's on top right
that means there are how many cards
remaining you already calculated it
there were
43 cards remaining
but that means the special card
when you put the 43 on top right the
special card was one underneath this one
so it was positioned you wrote it down
44. okay so position 44 maybe if you've
got another color
we'll put a big box around this because
this is kind of the key right
now then what did we do well we made
four piles
of cards in front of us right and the
important number that we were actually
going towards was like four or lots of
11 right that's what gave us 44. does
that make sense so it's really four
piles of 11 and you would get to 11 if
you counted all the way down to zero
right but actually I didn't say to count
down from 11 I said to count down from
10 because it's it's one less than that
because let's suppose if I counted down
from five right it'd go five four three
two one and then you'd put down a zero
card so there would be six cards there
now right so that's that's one extra
okay so therefore if we want four piles
of 11 we count down
from
10. make sense okay all right now this
is the whole trick this is it right so
we want to do the transformation
[Music]
so here's what I'm going to do right I
suggested to you what if we change the
numbers that we've got here okay there's
really only two numbers that get us to
position 44. can you see which of the
numbers that make 44
it's there it's the four and the 11
right these are the two numbers that
matter this is how many piles you've got
right and in fact if you want it's kind
of this 11 I draw your attention to this
10 really right so let's call this the
the sort of countdown pile right
okay so let's change both of those
numbers by saying who knows what those
are and we have a whole area of math
devoted to when you've got numbers but
you don't know how big they are or how
small they are and so because you can't
say it's four or five or six you have to
give it some alternative name you have
to put like say for example a letter in
front of it like X or Y or whatever now
this is piles so why don't we choose a
letter like
P for piles because I mean I could call
it X or Y but I might as well choose a
letter that tells me that reminds me
what the thing is does that make sense
and we do this all the time you guys
know like the area of a circle is what's
the formula pi r squared and we call it
R because it stands for radius you might
as well use a letter that helps you so
we're going to have P piles right and
then there's some other number here that
we count down from right so because it's
the countdown number let's call that c
get him
really really okay
so these are the numbers that are going
to be key right
now think about this with me let's now
reverse engineer I'm going to go back
through this in Reverse if this is the
countdown number then really I've got to
actually when I'm doing this trick I've
got it allowed I don't say 11 I say one
less than that right so the number I see
allowed actually starts from not C but C
minus one very good C minus one okay so
far so good
so then I'm going to have P times C
that's this position right so the card
will be in position
P times C so I'll just put an orange box
around that just like it was before
so if that's the position I want to get
in
then how many cards do I have to take
away from the person and get Aria at a
shuffle right have a look what's the
relationship
it's just one less right so it's that
number P times C
take away one right so what I want to do
is say pay I might as well just say PC
that's the same as P times C take away
one
these are the cards cards
that I hold on to
these are the cards that the person
choosing doesn't get to choose from
right
so in this case was 43 which left you
with nine cards to choose from now last
piece to the puzzle have I got enough
colors uh was there a blue somewhere is
there a blue can you like throw it at me
please
good throw okay what's the relationship
and some of you most of you wrote it
down right from this number which is p
times C take away one what's the
relationship to that number
so yeah minus from 52 so this number
whatever it is I go 52 take away that
and it'll give me the number of cards to
hand over okay so I'm going to go 52
this is therefore 52 take away whatever
that was right P times C take away one
I can do better than that can't we
simplify this we've learned algebra
tools to do this right when you've got
this minus outside of these brackets
what happens it's going to be 52 take
away
that distributes to the PC and then here
I've got a double negative what happens
with a double negative that's plus one
plus one but I know what 52 plus one is
it's just
53 okay I'm ready to go now let's see if
I actually use this to transform my
trick suppose we don't want four piles
of 11 right maybe we want I don't know
five piles of
don't be too big a number because I've
only got so many cards in the in the day
how about okay let's go with seven five
pounds of seven okay now if I really
want five piles or seven I'm actually
going to when I do the trick I'm gonna
count down
from one less than that right C take
away one so I'm going to count down from
six when I do this okay and then well
how many cards am I going to give to you
now it's 53 take away P times C
53 take away five times seven can you
tell me what five times seven is
35 uh uh that looks to me like take away
30 gives you 23 take away the 5 gives
you
18. does that look right yeah because 18
plus 35 will get me back okay so let's
give it a whirl shall we